are you ready for this yes sir
you will keel
voice miss this is the Naga sword I'm
Joseph JoJo Salyers I am 19 years old
from rutherton North Carolina I am a
full-time blade Swiss with my dad Billy
Salyers who just so happens to be a
fortune fire Champion Billy you are the
forge of fire Champion good job brother
and so here I am hoping I can show the
old man up the Naga sword traces its
Origins back to 16th century India
featuring a broad Square chisel tip this
weapon was graded inflicting powerful
deadly chops in combat
this rare version of the Dow sword was
reserved for the highest level tribal
authorities due to the scarcity of iron
in the area while few Naga swords still
exist it can be seen on display in the
halls of the British museum in London
Matt's set of curb guitars
my name is Matthew Shirey I live in the
Smoky Mountains of North Carolina and I
think I'm ready to win I've got a wife
and two little boys we like to spend a
lot of time in the outdoors together I
think I can be pretty funny sometimes I
make my kids laugh anyway I don't know
about other people
while the Qatar was immensely popular in
India during the 16th and 17th century
this curved version is extremely rare
and has been hailed as one of the most
unique weapons in history the ornate
handle construction features two bars
for the grip and provides the user
enough control to make a very effective
fighting knife as a pair the curved
guitars were designed to deliver quick
and lethal stabs and slashes using both
arms today this one-of-a-kind weapon can
be seen on display at the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in New York
oh
I'm back in Rutherfordton North Carolina
and I'm ready to get started on this
Naga sword first thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna take all 31 of these pieces
of Damascus and we're going to clean
them off
we'll pull that out get it going
making my sword out of Damascus isn't
required but it adds an extra level to
the blade that I think will help me out
in the competition
coming along pretty well
I got a solubility Damascus time to get
my blade in the oil with Damascus you
have a bunch of little welds any of
those Wells could possibly pop open I'm
hoping everything comes out all good all
right hot metal
my swords quenched it's pretty straight
all in all my blades mostly done most of
the work I have to do is Aesthetics and
sharpening that is what you'd like to
see my dad was kind enough to give me
something to test my blade on challenge
worthy of your skills
finally oh we're the opponents
yeah so go on the wall
my swords comfy sharp it's done now it's
time to go see what the judges can do
with it
I'm back home here in Sylva North
Carolina and I'm super excited to get
started on these curved guitars
today I'm going to try to get the blades
forged and possibly the crossbars
my biggest concern is creating the
folders in the blade I'll put the piece
of Steel in between those two dies and
and Forge the full Earth
this is the part I was most nervous
about so I'm going to take it nice and
slow
[Music]
finally got my folders roughed in these
are the crossbars for the handle
challenges are going to be getting these
handles just right so I've just done
what's called a reverse twist there I've
got the frames fabricated for my my
blades and the crossbars and it's time
to start assembling them
my handle in round two wasn't quite
perfect and I want to make sure that
doesn't happen in the final round
got the handles attached to the blades
and uh ready for heat treat there's
always moment of truth I'm a little
nervous going into it
yep that one looks good getting number
two and we're good to go
[Music]
I feel ecstatic about my progress I'm
really pleased with the way they're
looking
late Smith's welcome to the kill test
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapons will do I'm going to take your
weapons and put some lethal blows or
chops on this big carcass JoJo are you
ready for this let's make some pork
chops you got it
foreign
pork chops you wanted pork chops you got
most of the wheat is right here in the
handle so that really lends itself to a
nice balanced weapon your sword's Edge
over here chops deeply especially that
one swing on the leg and overall it will
heal awesome Matthew you're interested
are you ready yes sir let's have fun
yeah
all right Matthew let's talk about your
curved guitars here first up I like the
scale of your blades because guitars are
the well the big daddies the push
daggers and push daggers are about to be
small so there's a scale that goes with
it to make it easier to control and I
think you've got that with your blades
the factory gives also a nice support
when I'm stabbing and slashing overall
sir your curved guitars you'll kill
thank you
all right gentlemen welcome to the
strength test the how to chop now those
how does would be riding on top of an
elephant this test is not about what
your Naga swords do to the how to but
what that how it does to your blades and
JoJo you are up first you ready
I suppose so
all right so JoJo uh there's there's no
damage it's a kind of an ax grind but
not a chopper it works fine it held up
beautifully in strength test well done
thank you Matthew you ready let's do it
okay
good
so Matthew write off good traditional
look to these I like that a lot they cut
like they're supposed to cut they're
plenty strong they held their Edge
beautifully good job thank you
forged in fire war of weapons